Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Deep Space Waifu.
Now...
Hear me out.
This is NOT a game where you go into space and shoot the clothes off of giant... (hmm...)
Planet-sized women (fat shaming?). That would be weird, that's not what we're doing here. In this game, (no
wrong game, definitely wrong game)
we are shooting the clothes off of giant, planet-sized women..
.. in SPACE.
Uh... ;-;
Okay, so.. thi..this game...
-exhale of despair and preparation of what to come-
This game.. i-
-rethinks existence-
Alright so I can explain..
What's happening here, and I will. So, you see this. It's like Mr.
Massagy in terms of the dating app, or any dating app. Now..
There are women here-- WhoOAh? I don't know what I did. No. No. No
WhoOa. Okay, so I've got Motoko SOOda...
Sarah Dorner, and
Tomoko Aoi,
Right? Okay, so.. this
game is
like a dating app.
Except that you.. uhh
Except that you are
in space.. shooting the clothes off of giant, planet sized women. (Hunie Pop 2?)
"Mangaka dream drawing. I've been reading manga since I was born! I may be only eighteen, but I've read every manga out there.
I've eaten manga. I've breathed manga. (Yummy..)
I LIVE FOR MANGA-DESU! As the queen of the Japanese sequential art
aficionado's, I draw 22 hours a day to become the best mangaka ever, datte bayo!"
[Japanese voices within Mark's imagination]
Did I hear that voice or was that the voice of someone judging me from my family?  Ghosts.. STOPLOOKINGATME (DEMONDS JIM!)
So.. oOoooooOOO
Classic power bullet cleaner (???)
Oh bullet CLEANER, okay, all right. I get that.
Slow-motion half speed clothes--
*Mark mentally dying*
aaAAAAAAAAaaAaaAAAA
UUUUMMmmm-UH
"Speedrun devil, double speed and damage."
That sounds nice and doesn't have anything to do with tearing off clothes
"Waifu: The Ultimate Word of Power"
*losing it*
All right, hear me out guys. It's NOOOTT- This is NOT a porn game! (thats what she said) *in denial* It's a very well polished..
Shmup. *yikes was that a good word to use*
Even though the developers referred to it as a "strip-'em-up" that does NOT mean that it is..bad.
I'm just gonna go with cLaSsiC?
Bullet cleaner...
Ooh ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
"Gentleman's mode.. mouse-only mode, super-casual." Oh, it's like one hand mode for lefties.
Now why would you only need to play with one hand?
*mind processing...*
*realization hits* ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I DUNNO..!
"Faster gentlemen's mode: you want to marry your waifu, so you need to show her that you're the perfect gentleman.
This is the ultimate challenge mode. Destroy any part of any clothes, and it's *dying* date over!
Practice, get good you can truly become her SENPAI! One-hand mode will be disabled." *dying even more*
Alright, so I'm gonna do speed of my motorcycle..
Oh, HELL yeah. Let's max out that bad boy. "Joystick deadzone.."
I don't know what that means, but I--let's slow.
Let's slow her down. Let's take it do it nice
You know Barry Manilow level who's I don't I didn't use that word Barry White
Okay, let's go oh my god
We went in the ocean??
Hi, hello? Waifu: Are you ready?
No, I'm not excuse me. Ma'am. I'm sorry
Why are you huge? Oh?
going, I'm sorry
Am going that way apparent. Why am I okay alright? Well I?
Am on a motorcycle. I am in space. I'm shooting
I'm shooting *giggles*
It- it's not what you think mom don't walk in here
mOoOm! I'm sorry  it's not what you think it is! Guys, so I swear, there's this game has depths, and it's got story
It's got a lot of reasons why I'm playing it right now
Oh geez- nice tootsies
uUuU-
Anyway
just you know, it's it's cold out space you should keep your socks on lady I
I got a rocket launcher. That sounds very official in game like
Which is what I'm doing. Playing a game- okay?
Ma'am I'm sorry (x4)
I should have been playing in True Gentleman mode. How am I supposed to avoid? I gotta shoot the enemies!
They're kind of in the way of clothes, er god. I shouldn't be playing this game. There's no excuse for it. Ah
What am I shooting? I don't wanna know-
Uh- what is happening?
Why are you doing that!? is it windy in space- oh gee, it's is there a draft in here
Or is it just you? I'm sorry! (x5)
UuAaAA!
Nothing I say is good! Get away, evil doer!
[scrEam]
OH- I'm sorry! (x6) This is not my intention! LADY!
Lady, I'm sorry (x7) you are
Huge and are probably threatening-
*giggles* You're probably threatening all of mankind
I mean, if we're all to be perfectly honest here, if we all, one day, in the night sky, looked up and saw a giant *hesitation* *processes the situation*
Planet sized lady
anime girl, specifically-
Smiling down at us. We would be very very scared so...
Sorry (x8), ah you know I managed to
Avoid that this is good not looking at nothing closer at 7 hello. Oh hi not doing nothing (Mark englishes good)
Not doing nothing
Nope, nope I'm over here now
Hello, that's a nice star right there. That's a good one. Okay. All right. Sorry.  Sorry  sorry (x11)
all right, sorry, sorry (x13)
Sorry, sorry (x15)
I ge- this game is on Steam by the way this game is available on Steam *nervous justification*
I'm not telling you to get it or nothing. I'm just saying like for the sake of
You know, (no i don't know mark) pointing out certain things this game is about- this game is on Steam so it cannot be
Super pornographic. There's rules and such. I mean Huniepop was on Steam, but you know that was slightly sensored-
YEEAH! YEAH LADY!
Oh (WHATDIDYOUDO!!!!!!)
Too much intimacy. I'm sorry (x16) that didn't mean to celebrate my victory
Hello, hi Oh boss fight indeed okay? Hi? Oh, what is that? Oh? I'm sorry (x17). Oh No tHE BRA!
Ma'am I'm sorry (x18). I'm not doing anything. I'm just trying to hit the boss ah I'm sorry (x19) zero put clothes on button
I'm just trying to hit the-
aH, IM DEAD!?
IM DEAD!!
Well maybe that's for the best okay alright, okay, I'm gonna play back to where I was because
Just shooting bad guys nothing weird about that
Mmm. I'm very sorry (x20) about whatever just happened oh
Sorry, sorry (x22) ma'am. No. No okay. Well alright, okay?
He's gotta get
Not gonna shoot that nope not gonna. Do it. I'm the gentleman as a gentlemanly game screwed in the boss yep
Nope, nope nope nope that's not yes now what I'm going for I don't want to die again. So it's all good
Everything's fine. Nope sorry (x23) no sorry (x24) didn't know you don't one. That's that well. I'm done
Okay, we did it yay alright. We got it. Well well
Well nope not gonna look over here. Wow. This is a nice knee hahaha. Oh
Trying to take a picture of the knee
I'm sorry Im sorry (x26) lady
I'll pay for the damage I caused
Anyway, nice pillow All Right see ya, how about leave now girl unlock great. Okay cool
Righty, then well. We've got a few
options
Nice. Oh, you look like Yuri from tokidoki literature club well
Mitsui cat to geary
Hey there. My name is Mitsui category
I'd say more about myself
But I only have a 5-minute break in my 24/7 study program after all I must have the best GPAs in the galaxy
Otherwise my family will disown me
I'm a very future will be in jeopardy
And we all know the future it's much more important than parties are fun
Or life itself study Batumi study damn you woman study
This profile is meant for study partners only 24/7 galactic study program to reach the best B
GPAs in the galaxy to be the best student is my dream, and I'll use every single second to study
I'll overcome this challenge and nothing will stop me if you have any motivational phrases stuff. Please link them to me tks
Okay all right
Square roots round roots test test says lucky school attire pop quiz help me a plus only five more years senpai
I sleep at school the ultimate student. Okay, all right well
alright you a
super casual
those super cash
Okay, alright
There's a good game. This is a good game guys is hi. Hello. You are gigantic. Why are you here? Why are you odd?
I'm sorry. (x27) I'm not what a would what are you on huh? I am sorry (x28)
I'm not looking. I'm not looking. I swear. I'm sorry (x29)
IM SORRY! (x30) it's drafty in here. I'm not looking I swear
Im so sorry! (x31)
I'm sorry everybody watching. I'm sorry everybody at home. I'm sorry everybody. I'm sorry for everything. I'm sorry for recording this video (x36)
I'm sorry. I'm sorry (x38) you have to die
I don't know. What's happening here or why all I know is that everybody has to die cuz I like shmups I do
I'm sorry. I'm so you got a face on your buttons. Yeah, I'm sorry.(x40) I noticed that study study study
You need why are you? Why are you 10 miles? Tall oh?
ow I'm sorry, I'm
Sorry, (x42) I feel bad. Okay, stop senpai all right. I'm sorry. Yeah, I'm sorry (x43)
I never take my glasses off
Okay
Sorry (x44) mmm so intimate sorry (x45)
Sorry Sorry excuse me sorry nope not shooting that sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry sorry. I'm sorry
I'm very sorry oh (x56)
Okay, I used my BAM
He's my pet. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.(x61) I'm oh I don't like that I
Don't like that at all okay. Got it nailed it nailed it, okay, alright. Okay, alright here. We go here we go
There we go got it okay alright did it okay alright? You're not naked great. That's a plus in my book
Take a nice picture of this knee nice knee real nice knee there. We go whoops not why I handed
Alright, see ya. Oh okay. Thank you. Why are you reading weed mag key alright girl unlock great?
Is that a yandere unlock the yandere girl? XD
Yep, that is the yandere girl!
You mean matsuda
Okay, aren't you cute you're so cute. It makes me feel like ripping your eyes out
I think I already love you, and if it tries to get in the way. I'll strangle them with their own bloody guts
Why do I need their blood type knife strings violence rip your heart out torture?
Love you cut you to pieces pain. You won't leave stay forever
Okay, it's a good game. This is a good game. I feel good about this. Hi. Yep sure AM Wow
Yep, I am okay. Hello. Hi. Where are you sleeping?
Why is giant space lady sleeping? I'm sorry (x62)
Can someone please count how many times? I've said I'm sorry  (x63 [Youre welcome Mark] in this game. I'm very sorry.(x64) I do not mean to do that
I'm sorry. I am very sorry. I'm sorry (x67) nice tootsies. Why do you have blood on your socks? That's what I'm
Okay, well you don't have socks my mistake
oh
Hello hi what the hell
What the hell Wow okay, I'm dead apparently okay, this is actually getting difficult, they have to focus on this one I'm a good
It's mops. I'm a good itch mops
Hi. Hello, how are you doing? Oh very sorry (x68) about that Oh, too intimate
I agree if you can back up a little bit. That'd be great. I know you're ahh sorry
Sorry (x70) didn't know what I was shooting at very sorry about that. Oh, sorry. Sorry. Sorry sorry (x75)
Ah, nope not not what I'm shooting at nope all right good
Okay, all right fine fine fine fine fine. I'm sorry. Hi. I'm sorry (x77)
I'm very oh
There we go
Nope nope nope, sorry! (x78) oh boy.
Geez it can't be like it can't actually be
It can't actually be like
It's got to be censored right. That's that's my thing right?
To live life in the fullest you must make the best of the time you have as such there are two hours for my date
on my skin daily schedule after that you have 30 minutes to take me home further activities can be conducted on Tuesdays and Fridays at
9:10 Andy the lights will be noted three delays in you're out life is scheduled the universe is scheduled your scheduled boy
So I'll give it straight you want to do this you have two hours to get me
30 minutes to take me home further activities can be conducted on Tuesdays and Fridays from 9:00 to 10:00 p.m.
The top for this message is over
Okay
All right, whatever you say. Why are these giant body pillows in space?
I don't understand all right. I'm going I'm
Getting your heel tickle tickle. Oh who's got it ticklish in all you do here. We go. Oh?
Who's got a shin the size of Long Island you do oh?
You've got legs that go on for literally infinity oh
I'm sorry (x79) I
Was aiming for your legs, I don't know what happened to your skirt. Hey. Hey look listen listen lady listen
I've played a lot of huniepop in my day. I know all about
how to flirt properly with the ladies and
shooting them with lasers while you're in space and their gigantic is
Way up high on that list let me tell you something ooh
That was a lot of points
Listen later
Okay, all right. I am sorry (x80) ah hey
Hey, you know I just you know I like my ladies strong
I just don't know if I like him to be able to plaque crack a planet in half. You know what I mean oh
Oh, oh, it means. I mean I'm not sure they're nothing but I feel kind of small this juncture too much intimacy
You know I'd kind of agree with that 100
G's
It's gotta be censored right oh
My god, I'm sorry (x81)
Oh god. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I am sorry. I am very sorry. I am sorry ah
Im very sorry, Im very sorry (x88) oh jeez oh jeez
Okay, all right cool great
Oh geez oh geez oh geez scoop. Oh geez
Oh geez Wow Chickie's hi. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry (x92)
It's Bob. I'm sorry. Did I mention how sorry I am hi. I'm sorry.(x95)  I am dodging oh
Hey
Who I am sorry (x96)
garbage
IM SORRY, IM SORRY, IM
Sorry (x99) I'm not looking you're not lucky. We're not looking I have now
I'm not looking. I'm not looking. I'm not looking. I am not looking. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry
I'm sorry. I am sorry. I'm sorry. I didn't mean that. I'm sorry. (x107) I'm putting the game down
I'm sorry (x108) anyway. Now is deep space waifu. I think I'm done for now. Thank you everybody so much for watching
I'm Sorry (x109) [New Highscore]
Please let me know what you think down the comments below. I will not provide a link to this game in the description
I guess I should out of all fairness and team did work hard on it, but at the same time
This game is also. I should point out if this game is
Overwhelmingly positively rated by the way
Hi, Kat. Yeah, I can't imagine why these giant planets size growth you know if I if we saw a giant planet sized girl
I'd like to think I'm not trying to rip their clothes off
I'm just trying to kill them in whatever way I can and their clothes are their only weak point I
guess
Anyway, so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know he thought down the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video